make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our beyond Omega level video
we'll be focusing on venom now that
might sound odd to a lot of you who know
that venom as he traditionally is
depicted is nowhere near being an Omega
level threat much less beyond Omega
level but today we're talking
specifically about venom as he appears
in venom V in a one-shot written by
Andrew Warren and drawn by Geoffrey
Cruise and published in January of 2020
and if you guys have not read this it's
absolutely insane but it's also pretty
awesome but we'll get to that here in a
little bit now as we always do we'll
briefly go over the origin of venom
before we get into this specific version
so the venom that we're all familiar
with was created by david michelinie and
todd mcfarlane and debuted in the
amazing spider-man number 300 in 1988
now originally the origin of venom was
that the black suit spider-man received
during 1984 Secret Wars crossover was
actually an alien symbiote that bonded
to Peter Parker and after being rejected
by Peter the symbiote bonded with Eddie
Brock creating the villainous venom
linear however Venom's origin would be
changed so that he was actually created
by the god-king null with an army of
other symbionts and that he had actually
bonded with a Kree soldier named tel car
before he had ever encountered Peter
Parker but in this normal safe
Venom's powers include all of
spider-man's abilities like
wall-crawling and web slinging due to
its contact with Peter Parker and is
also able to escape detention of Peter
Parker's spider sense he's also capable
of shape-shifting size alteration
camouflage telepathically communicating
with its hosts and additionally the
physical attributes of the Venom
symbiote star greatly augmented but
absolutely none of that has anything to
do with why venom is beyond Omega level
in the story venom the end so let's just
really get into what happens in this
ridiculous story so the story starts out
by saying that it is the final venom
story and it occurs 1.8 million years
after the Venom symbiote first bonds
with Eddie Brock and at the time when
all biological life in existence is
about to go extinct now we are told as
we've seen in Donnie cages venom run
that the Venom symbiote contains all the
DNA of each of its previous hosts this
database which is referred to as a
tesseract is effectively endless in its
capacity which will come into play later
on in a big way I'll have I don't have
any eggs on what my omelet Gordon don't
cut this out leave this in the video
mariah is making me an omelet guys
see we see we keep a professional here
at common six more we keep it
professional here right 100%
professional economist explain we run
our business seriously no we don't we
don't we goof off in our videos oh I
don't know like like three or four eggs
I don't I'm not picky doesn't matter to
me but before we move on I want to clear
up any confusion that the reference to a
tesseract may cause as some people may
have chosen to refer to this version of
venom as tesseract venom now when you
hear the word tesseract you probably
think of the artifact of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that was effectively
the cinematic counterpart of the Cosmic
Cube from Marvel Comics that is not
what's being referenced here and the
term just refers to the four dimensional
nature of venom that allows the symbiote
to house a limitless genetic code X
within itself but anyway as a story
progresses we see that although the
Venom symbiote has had thousands of
house it develops an extremely strong
attachment to one of them in particular
Eddie Brock to that end as Eddie's body
begins to die the symbiote began
replacing his organs with replacements
made from its own anatomy expanding
Eddie's lifespan to hundreds of years to
the point that he was the last human on
earth now that statement begs the
question why is he the last human if
this is only hundreds of years into the
future well what we end up seeing is
that an arms race between alien
civilizations such as the Kree and the
Shi are ushered in an era of
self-replicating nano weaponry called
the artificial superintelligence that
traveled from solar system to solar
system eliminating all organic life in
each of them and so in an effort to
preserve biological life venom tries to
convince his fellow symbiotes to save
the respective hosts to begin a new
civilization but was unsuccessful in
doing so their disagreement resulted in
a war between the symbiotes a war that
left venom and its only survivor now
with the rest of the simians gone venom
decides that to preserve life he will
have to build his own army and to do
that Venom's hatched into its Codex and
accesses the genes of Jaime madrix the
multiple man and uses it to create a
seemingly infinite number of copies of
itself now 1,000 years later we see
venom has spread billions of copies over
thousands of galaxies seeding them with
life and biospheres called meat gardens
and in doing this venom taps into its
Codex to draw on the mutant
of elixir to manipulate biology storm to
aid in terraforming planets in order to
have conditions sustainable for growing
life and Wolverine and Deadpool to allow
its creations to have the ability to
heal now during the thousand years that
venom was growing his army the
artificial superintelligence have been
growing one as well their emissary an
artificial intelligence version of Tony
Stark meets with venom in an attempt to
convince him that the best thing for his
biological creations would be to allow
them to assimilate into a digital
existence so that they could live
forever
now when venom refuses his forces end up
going to war with the artificial
superintelligence following this venom
consults with some of the more brilliant
minds stored away in his codex including
Reed Richards in T'Challa and through
some subatomic matter manipulation
alters the genetic makeup of his army to
give them claws capable of shattering
entire planets still Venom's army was
unable to gain the upper hand as their
organic nervous system simply could not
compete with the Nano text computer
processors in terms of speed now to
compensate for this venom draws on the
DNA of Quicksilver and supercharges it
to give him SuperSpeed and while this
gave Venom's forces an upper hand
temporarily moving at such speed proved
too much for even the enhanced biology
of venom soldiers to endure and billions
of them succumb to death as they aged
through their lifespans near
instantaneously but venom would not give
up using the powers of mutants tempest
timeslip and magic venom goes back in
time and literally bonds with every
living thing that has ever existed
meaning not only people but animals
plants bacteria literally everything and
so what this did was turned venom into a
database containing the entirety of the
universe's biological matter by this
point though the artificial
superintelligence had become even more
advanced and are so deadly that they
become known as the god mind having
assimilated 75% of the universe and
killed the last remaining Celestials
Galactus and even the Living Tribunal
now before this final battle with the
god mind
Venom's final host dies signaling the
end of biological life in the universe
and knowing that defeat was imminent
venom basically rips himself apart and
what happens next is somewhat confusing
but what ends up essentially happening
here is that venom creates a new
universe by expelling his
four-dimensional Anatomy into the
universe that destroys the fabric of
space and time now yeah I know that
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
but I told you this is basically going
to be crazy but the important thing
is venom sacrifices himself to create a
new universe where all the organic life
that venom carried in his codex is
returned to life and all of it even
place in its proper position and the
time stream by Venom's ability to alter
time and so basically venom recreates
the universe in the exact way it had
existed before the artificial
superintelligence destroyed it and
according to the artificial stark
intelligence the god mind resolved to
not repeat their extinction event in
this new universe and would leave it as
a nature preserve of sorts for
Biological life so yeah totally bonkers
stuff but essentially this version of
venom is way beyond omega-level in fact
he's basically a beyond omega-level
character he's insanely powerful not
only does he have the power of seemingly
every mutant that ever existed he's able
to create life manipulate matter and
travel through time even the beings that
he created or at least Omega level which
each of them having the ability to
destroy planets venom is effectively
immortal having lived for over a
trillion years and was able to create a
new universe and manipulate the reality
within it so yeah like I said this
version of venom is well beyond Omega
level but without being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come and explain make
sure you guys to the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if he wants
to keep up our videos professional and
joking around talking to Mariah is she's
she's struggling to open a can of her a
package of chopped up ham to put in the
omelet
she said if I just don't mind my
business what are you gonna do
sweetheart she said I'm not gonna eat
that omelet okay I need to mind my own
business
cuz Mariah does know how to throw it
down to the kitchen guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end I love you
all to death I'll catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]